dot net core and all those goodies today
oh there's the mic even better just real
quick this is a useless slide I'm sure
but I'm the chief architect of DevOps
and modern software insight
I am a Microsoft Regional Director and
MVP it means I do not work for Microsoft
but I do know a lot of them real well so
if you have questions or feedback around
some of the things they're doing here I
can certainly try to help or get it to
the right folks and I know that they
really want to hear what everyone was
planning on doing and you know what
their thoughts are on this topic in
particular but the best way to reach me
is on Twitter I am very responsive there
so you know please follow me if you have
questions after this I'm always happy to
help and that's really the best way to
get a hold of me just a quick survey
here how many folks here are doing WPF
or Windows forms work for the day-to-day
jobs everyone ok good I knew here not
doing windows forms anyone's like not
know what it is ok yeah put your head
down ok well so you're in good company
here just may be one step further
are these new applications anyone
building a new application they just
started within the last say two years
good so you active development and how
many folks are doing it was just like
maintenance bug fixes keep the lights on
but we're not really doing anything okay
a few of those and that's really what we
expect and you know if you've been
coming to these conferences for a while
have you felt a bit left out so all this
web content blaze are super cool but I'm
working on the desktop what's for me
maybe a little bit you're not alone so
just to one quick number here coming
from ignite this past year there's over
2.4 million developers every month using
Visual Studio to build desktop
applications it may not have been the
thing that Microsoft and others have
been talking about over the past few
years but there's absolutely no shortage
of people who are like you are doing
this on a day to day basis so it's a
very large quantity of people here and
you know this isn't really a Windows 10
talk but you know the Windows 10
migration is coming along Windows 7 is
end-of-life in less than a year now
thank you
so hopefully most of your organizations
are well on their way towards moving to
Windows 10 and if they haven't yet have
at least concrete plans at this point to
do so how many folks here have heard of
dotnet core everyone very good that's a
better number then if I asked this
question last year so you know then that
dotnet core is Microsoft's open source
cross-platform framework which up until
now hasn't had much of a story for the
desktop what's coming now though is part
of net core 3 our support for new
platforms and it really is about moving
the platform forward and that's to add
support for things like AI and IOT but
most exciting for me is the desktop
because I am a desktop developer at
heart that's where I started my career
at some of the financial institutions
writing trading systems and you know I
the stuff that the web guys are just
dealing with now we're dealing with 15
years ago come on high performance
concurrency multi-threaded trading grids
yeah yeah come back to me when it gets
hard so this is a space that has been
really neglected up until now and it's
I'm really thrilled to see this get some
attention on dotnet for 3so dotnet core
3 is bringing support for Windows forms
high DPI that is one where how many
folks show of hands WinForms explicitly
exclusively yeah good
Windows forms is still to this day the
easiest way in my opinion to write an
app I mean I love WPF but you're not
going to beat the windows forms designer
it's just drag those text boxes out
there you double-click and you have an
app and you can go about your day well
if you've tried to run this on a high
DPI screen so far you've probably
noticed it doesn't work very well and
there's bits because the fixes that are
required for high DPI
would break the dotnet framework would
break compatibility with somebody
someone somewhere would complain and
Microsoft wouldn't hear the end of it
and therefore they just can't do it so
one of the key benefits of dotnet core 3
is that it can be installed side by side
and I will say this again and again
because it is in my opinion the reason
everyone here should care about it how
many folks here are running on dotnet 4
7 2 in their companies whew
ok for 7 4 6
ok anyone still on for 5 please tell me
it's at least 4 or 5 - because 4 5
hasn't been n support for a quite a
while
they have X there's probably exploits in
the wild that's art there so I would
suggest that they at least look into the
4 or 5 to update to it get those fixes
but that illustrates the key point here
there are reasons why organisations have
not updated dotnet framework and that's
because it's a global machine wide
installation so be with dotnet core
being able to be side-by-side
applications can opt into it explicitly
and it gives you as a developer the
flexibility that you didn't really have
with the.net framework so with that you
can do things like host uwp controls in
wind forms or WPF how many folks
remember are actively using the element
host controls in wind forms to host WPF
a few how about the other way using from
WPF hosting when you know windows forms
yeah this isn't really a surprise here
because you're not going to sit there
and say I have this windows forms lap or
this windows forms controller WPF
control I'm not going to rewrite it
that's silly
but I do want to use it similar story
here with you WP and that's saying look
no one is really gonna write or rewrite
their
app in you WP you know that was
Microsoft's they they tried that and
everyone kind of laughed in their face
because why would you throw out your
perfectly good code and rewrite it in
this other language or other set of
screens there's no business value there
but you might want to use their text box
with inking support or maybe you want to
use the edge webview because its current
instead of the ancient ie11 that's in
the web browser control or perhaps you
want to use the new modern maps control
that's more efficient and faster there's
a lot of scenarios where the uwp
controls have things in there that you
want to use but you need to be you're
not gonna rewrite your app so you need a
way of using them in your existing app
and that's what the sam'l Island
technology allows you to do so that is
supported in dotnet core 3 the other fun
one is that you can actually deploy this
as a self-contained executable that's
just a single file some XE just put it
on a thumb drive or network share and
run it and we'll be looking at some of
that in greater depth in a few minutes
talked a little bit about this but side
by side is certainly the big one but you
have performance improvements as well so
the dotnet framework is on a lot of
machines I don't know exact numbers if
it's in the billion at this point it's
possible but any change there is gonna
undergo you know heavy regression
testing strict scrutiny blah blah blah
you can't change things without risking
breaking code now if you've been
following any of the dotnet core 2
development cycle especially two one
there's been a huge push on optimization
reducing allocations making sure making
it so that you can rewrite allocation
free code wherever possible through
api's with span of T reference structs
and all sorts of you know making unsafe
code safe again through static
allocation techniques well all of those
are based on net core to one types and
are likely never really gonna make it
into the dotnet framework for example
string no one really really wants to
touch string and they're not in that
framework if you messed something up in
there that would be bad but there's a
bit more flexibility to experiment and
move forward
on the.net framework or start down at
core because of the side-by-side
capability if there's some new behavior
some new overload resolution some new
type that gets added
you had to opt into that to get it
you're someone updating your version of
the.net framework on your box isn't
gonna just make your app stop working
which is exactly what happened in some
unfortunate cases with the.net framework
so I mean at 100% compatibility is
extremely difficult even behavioral
changes your you might be relying on an
API to throw meanwhile it gets fixed and
now it doesn't throw the API didn't
change but the behavior did is that a
bug is that the framework like one
person's bug is another person's feature
that they were counting on and you just
broke them another huge one here is the
fact that it's open source and I don't
think that it's easy to overstate that
because if there's a bug or some issue
you've run into that's affecting your
particular scenario it's possible to go
in to the underlying framework work with
the.net team work with the community and
fix it or if there's a new API that
you're saying look we really are trying
to do this thing it would be really
convenient if I don't know the zamel
window class exposed I don't know an H
wind handle for some reason I'm making
stuff up but if there's something that's
in there those are the kinds of
discussions you could have in there and
get that code contributed into the main
framework where it'll just ship for
everybody heck if you really want to
build it and maintain your private Fork
of this stuff you can do that too
I don't recommend that but you
the flexibility with any open source
project to do that so that's a
significant benefit so that's to say
with the.net framework it's gonna slow
down it's really going to have critical
bug fixes and mandatory feature updates
like I imagined TLS 1.3 when the new
version of TLS comes out it's probably
gonna be there it's not going to get
huge amounts of new features it's also
not going away anytime soon dotnet
framework is a Windows component it's
tied to the full lifetime of Windows
which is at least 10 years from the
current release let's see it's 2019 so
let's say at least 2029 and then the
next version of Windows will keep
pushing it up because it's still a
Windows component also many of
Microsoft's major lines of business and
things like exchange or other massive
products are built on the.net framework
it doesn't make business sense for them
to rewrite it in their scenario they're
not frameworks not going anywhere so
just something to be clear just because
dotnet core is the shiny new thing
that's not to say that you should like
you have to rewrite everything a risk
you know the dotnet framework going away
or losing support of any kind not at all
what I would say is that if you're
looking to take advantage of new
platform features and you want the
platform that's evolving and moving
faster then dotnet core 3 is something
to start looking at especially since now
it'll cover the desktop scenarios that
it didn't support in the past another
way of thinking about it if you're just
if you're maintaining an app not really
adding any new features just saying look
a bug fix here and there patch it keep
the lights on leave it alone it's not
worth anyone's time or effort to update
and port that if you're actively
building new features onto it and saying
look this is under active development we
need to move it forward and it's you
know it's in a critical app for us
it's a good time to start looking at
moving that over to dotnet core three
and you know we'll explore how to do
that here the current status of dotnet
core 3 is that they just released
preview to a few days ago it was
announced the first release was in
connect back in December that you do
need Visual Studio 2019 preview to play
with donek or three I will add that
Visual Studio 2019 and the previews
install completely side by side with
2017 so you don't have to worry about
messing up your 2017 instance use 2017
that's where you're getting your
day-to-day work done you can also
install 2019
you know without fear of inner you know
mixing stuff so I'm gonna make that
clear the designers are not yet here
it's just and we'll show you some
workarounds of how to use the designer a
different way but you know it will come
at some point you know I imagine before
it ships just so you know that's just
the current state of where we are today
the other one is that WPF windows forms
and the windows UI library have been
made open-source that was a big
announcement at Kinect as well so the
all of the sam'l technologies are there
they're in there getting you know more
open source over time it's last I
checked the WPF stuff had some bits in
there and I get as the team is you know
figuring out how to get stuff there
you'll see more right that's a pretty
big change for the the windows team to
move stuff into the public so that's
really awesome if you're looking to
migrate a dotnet framework app there's a
few steps I would suggest the first
thing is to look at the dotnet
portability analyzer it's going to give
you a roadmap of you know what are we
know what does it expect will just work
it'll help flag any api's you might be
using that might be different or in some
cases that are not supported
I will every almost everything is
supported on deck or three however
things like app domains and remoting are
absolutely not supported they are there
by design not gonna be moved forward if
you are using things like remoting the
recommendation would be to look at
another messaging protocol like G RPC or
other similar RabbitMQ use something
else remoting is not coming
the other one is app domains where there
is another solution for loading
assemblies side by side it's beyond the
scope of this talk but there's
information online on how to how to do
that but just know that there would be a
change for that scenario the other one
how many folks that are using or still
on packages dot config if you go to your
project file is there a file called
package dot config hiding in there a few
okay so in the latest versions of Visual
Studio and this is kind of they they
shipped it and then kind of forgot to
tell anyone it was there you can
right-click that packages dot config
file and say migrate to package
reference and it will look at your
dependencies tree shake to get rid of
all the transitive ones and keep only
the ones you really need to have
directly referenced in there and convert
that for you I would go bottom-up start
with your libraries and then go library
by library and you know just migrate
them and verify that it still works but
it's definitely something I would do
tomorrow or on Monday when you're back
at the office after this conference you
can do this even without moving to
dotnet core 3 this is package reference
has a newer mechanism for using nougat
and has a huge number of benefits for
that including transitive dependencies
and getting rid of all that mess in your
packages config file so something you
can do as soon as possible but it's
absolutely required if you're going to
move over to dotnet core 3 at that point
I would move over to your libraries and
if you're targeting dotnet framework I
would look at moving it to either dotnet
standard or der
dot neck or three directly the
advantages of using dotnet standard
would be that you can use the libraries
dotnet standard without updating the
rest of your app one by one and the
dotnet standard library will continue
working on the dotnet framework and you
can go layer by layer and making sure
things work so it's something you can do
over time or cut the branch say look
we're gonna switch it over to dotnet
core 3 directly and you know either way
I think you'll find that it's actually
may be easier than you expect so one
thing I can't say enough test everything
thoroughly this is a platform change
while API surface area may be compatible
there could be some runtime differences
and that really the only way to verify
that is to go through every single
function that your application has and
do it did it work as you expect yeah I
know that most folks are probably don't
have full hundred-percent
UX full test coverage because it's hard
and brittle this is the kind of thing
that after making this change I would do
a full 100% regression test with
whatever teams or people you might have
for that to catch it I mean it might be
small things but I would definitely
count on doing that the other bit is
that dotnet framework is a machine wide
system that means that when your
application is out there Microsoft is
responsible for any security updates
Windows updates through your
organization or your customers
organization will get security patches
deployed machine wide dotnet core has
two main options of providing the
framework you can use the shared
framework which is installed machine
wide although side-by-side or you can be
self-contained which is basically xcopy
deploy take everything on a thumb drive
or it can be bundled into that single
EXCI we talked about the the downside
there is that you the developer are
responsible for secure
the updates because it's you're carrying
the full copy of the dotnet core
framework in your code so Machine wide
stuff is not going to affect it so
that's the double-edged sword the good
news and the bad news so if you were
going to do a self-contained deployment
just beware of the responsibility you
all need to do and have that object
update mechanism so that you can ship a
new version of your app that has an
updated core framework in it should the
need arise and we'll talk about how to
do that here in a moment one thing and
it says I realize this is you know you
know well it's a jumble here but this is
the workaround for some of the designer
issues at the moment where you can
create a CS an empty project and Link in
all of the existing files and then you
can use the designer from the dotnet
project system and have all the files be
compiled for dotnet core and it'll show
you that in Visual Studio here as well
but this is a point in time issue it's
probably more relevant for Windows forms
where it's hard to really do anything
without the designer many times a mole
can be done with or without the designer
I find it you know it's just easier to
do it that way so you may not need to do
this if you're just doing example so
next up we're going to take a look at
the performance benefits and as well as
show some of these workarounds I'm going
to switch over to the demo machine to do
that here so some of this you may have
seen over at the time but it's going to
call out a couple of key differences
this is a pie chart application that's
written for dotnet for and is also
compiled for the dotnet core framework
if I just show here the files that are
loaded you can see that it's loading
files up here from
the global assembly cache this is
regular dotnet framework application
that you're all know and love and what I
can do here is browse for a folder come
over and I'm gonna pick my dev folder
see dev and it's gonna go run through
and tell me how much stuff is in it and
the point here is really to show some of
the performance benefits that we're
gonna see and.net core if we observe it
takes about 4.2 seconds to run this
directory numeration api is just you
know no no big deal here it's also
happens to be using a telluric chart for
dotnet for WPF you know that's fine now
if I stop this and I open this up Visual
Studio will show me these linked files
and I know it's a bit small to see on
this screen there's a little blue
overlay and it has that's what you'll
see by hat by using those compile
include star star you know the wild-card
expression there you do not have to
specify every single file one by one in
the dotnet core projects anymore if I
run it let go start at the startup
project
I'm also referencing by the way the same
dotnet for version of the telluric
control dotnet core 3 will run most
dotnet for libraries unchanged you do
need to test it if you're using some
edge API but there's a pretty good
chance it will run now if we browse for
the folder the first thing we'll notice
is that the folder dialog browser looks
a little bit different no code changes
same code but this is one of the pull
requests that came in from the community
and was merged in over at the connect
announcement yeah Hanselman merged this
I shameless plug I actually did this PR
because the folder dialog was bugging me
and I was like how is it 2018 and we
don't have a modern folder dialog let's
fix this point is is that if there's
some part of Windows forums or something
else which
has been bothering you for a while and
it's never been at the top of anybody
else's list now is the time or now going
forward you can this open you can fix
this so we'll come back
choose the dev folder run this it now
and it's gonna run in under a second
fourfold faster same code different
platform and that's because of some of
the underlying performance benefits in
the.net core framework and that's the
key point here is that even if your app
is running just fine
just by moving platforms you can get
instant performance wins and on certain
systems which are either resource
constrained or you need that
high-performance or maybe you need to
get every last bit of juice because the
trader has six screens and 18 versions
of your app running as counts so
definitely something to think about here
now the dotnet framework so Visual
Studio today does not have file new
projects for WPF or Windows forms again
point in time thing I'm absolutely sure
it will be in a later preview for now
the way to get started is with a command
line and that's just to say dotnet new
WPF and that will create a the project
that you need and then you can open that
just fine in Visual Studio so if I come
up here explorer
and just drag this one over i'll open to
the file menu sure open object
dev NDC London it will open up just fine
and it will save the solution save yes
fine whatever why is it bugging me good
if we run it you know yay hello world
will pop up
hello dotnet cork it's really exciting
but it gives you everything you need and
if we were to open the project file
which you can do now just simply by
double-clicking the project itself you
can see this is all that's in it so if
you have ever looked at a project file
for WPF or Windows forms your eyes are
probably you know bleeding from fear if
you've ever had a merge conflict because
two of you have added files or changed
it from different branches yeah that's
all gone now
so like dotnet core and done that
standard projects almost everything is
implicit defaulted or otherwise now you
can always override all of that but you
don't need to for the vast majority of
cases so you can take advantage of all
those things now ona shift gears here
and switch over to another instance and
we're going to port an application right
here as well
just a quick show of hands how many
folks have used or aware of a tool
called the msbuild log viewer ok
Microsoft people you don't count ok have
any of you had a failing build and
saying hey what happened or maybe you're
trying to get that diagnostic output and
trying to read that 20 megabyte build
log file anyone yeah
so this is a tool you want to know about
because you add /bl dough bug to the
build parameter and it gives you a bin
log file which has all the deets
basically the everything that the blog
does in a compressed binary form that a
tool like this Microsoft I misspelled
structured log viewer can read and it
shows you everything in a nice tree and
you can search for errors and
double-click things and see the targets
right you can also then evaluate all the
items and properties and well this isn't
strictly a talk on this tool I will
point out that this is probably the
thing that can help people understand
the Voodoo of msbuild so if you really
try to say look why did my build go
crazy this tool will help you understand
it absolutely the I couldn't have done
what I do without this this is a
lifesaver what I do want to do though is
make this run on dotnet core 3 this is
right now it's WPF you know it's using a
tree view it's using the Avalon edit
controls right here there's a stock
component and it's a look that's nice
but I want to take advantage of some
newer functionality and what I'm gonna
start with is I'm gonna unload it and
it's some other project I'm gonna edit
it and this is the project file that you
know we all know and hate it's here
let's just make it go away yeah just so
you don't have to see me typing I do
have it in a snippet but the key here is
that this is almost the same as the file
new project template we at least the
command-line project template but I've
added in here a project reference to a
dotnet standard class library I already
did that as we talked about and adds a
couple of new get references this new
get reference here is the same Avalon
edit
version it's not a dotnet core three
project this is done it for WPF no
problem I'm gonna reload it
yes sure save it let's do a rebuild and
boom it says it's going to fail that's
okay because what it has in here are
three extra properties that you can
choose to either keep and turn off the
generation of or just delete msbuild
in the the new project system will
generate many or most of the assembly
level attributes for you so there's
almost no code changes but for those
ones I'm gonna delete them and if you
want to add them back we can come in to
the project properties add them under
the build settings and it will go ahead
and add them for you so you don't have
to complete this thing is getting
confused isn't it it
it looks like it didn't yeah keep it
oh that's Avalonia yeah open that one it
opens the other one didn't it edit okay
yeah that's right I don't know why I was
saying done at four six maybe Visual
Studio is getting confused that wouldn't
surprise me I was I did say it was
preview right
okay package that looks better here we
go
so this will give you all the properties
that we can add here whether it's
assembly versions the descriptions the
package IDs and all this so you don't
have to do this within your code and you
can configure this dynamically as part
of a build this is much easier that way
let me just rebuild it now we do have a
member of the project system in here and
I hope he's paying attention okay okay
so it says it should have finished let
go there we go rebuild and it should
succeed and it's giving me a couple of
warnings in here and the warnings here
are really just telling me that hey this
succeeded but it was restored or this
package was used the dotnet framework
version be you know there be dragons be
careful it should work but it's just
letting you know that and you can
suppress that warning if you're saying
yep got it
understand it's fine so I'm gonna go
ahead and say yep let's go launch it and
hopefully to no one's surprise it works
now and it looks the same because it is
the same but it is running on deathcore
three and I can come over here I open
the file it's gonna run I can come in
here you know I can see the XML with all
the syntax highlighting and it's running
the avilon edit WPF controls on Dec or
three and I say this is pretty awesome
I'm going to go check out and give the
off there some feedback
and bam it did say that there were
performance or behavioral differences
didn't I
so is code compatible but there are a
few things and this is one of them
where there are minor changes you may
need to make in the code so this is why
it's critical to test it and I'm pushing
them Microsoft to create a you know a
top issues document that would in least
include something like this but the
issue in this case is that we've used
process start to launch the URL and this
users default browser well that works
great on the dotnet framework where
everyone assumed it was just running on
Windows the behavior and dotnet core is
a little different and we need to
explicitly tell it to use shall execute
equals true to which is the equivalent
of what you would do in the Windows
Explorer or the run dialog in Windows
Explorer it is an easy change so let's
just come over here and go our psi
equals new process start
and then file path or file name here we
go with that here
psi and if we run it again we'll see
that it oh wait there's the stop button
stop all we did is change the process
start info we didn't actually set the
right parameter up use a shell execute
that's the magic there now it should
work as we expect if it starts up here
here we go and it helped launch the URL
and off we go yes I do use that as my
default browser I do like it and you can
fight me and that there is just again an
example there may be others but it's it
can be this easy as an anecdote how many
folks here are using our views and you
get package Explorer anyone heard of it
okay thank you for using it for the rest
of you it is a tool that can help view
NuGet packages if you're saying I need
to find one or I want to see what's in
it or maybe check that it might be
signed correctly or otherwise it's out
there and you can search either in the
Microsoft Store or on github or
chocolatiers it's out there a number of
different ways
it was a dotnet 4/5 application I moved
it over to nook or three early before
the preview 1 bits hit and it required
almost no code changes again so many of
these things here can be moved over very
easily I mean you might have something
to do like a process dot start like I
like I showed you here so let's come
back over to the deck for a moment
and move on to everyone's favorite topic
distribution so you could have a modern
application you've modernized it you're
running on dotnet core three and it's
self-contained but you still have to get
it to your users
now how many folks here have an internal
IT department that likes to muck up all
their binaries and repackage things
someone's not raising their hand guilty
yeah this is not an uncommon thing many
in organizations will take installers
send them off to their IT group who
knows better than everyone else and
repackage it for internal distribution
that can muck things up how many folks
here are using click once today anyone
MSI just plain building an installer
file
okay how about squirrel I need squirrel
users okay something else and it miss
something okay yeah seized with nougat
packages I like it so all of these
things here have a number of different
challenges that you might face one of
them is the repackaging and repackaging
apps takes time as well as can very
often break things up often clean
uninstallation of apps is not possible
because application bits go on a machine
and they'll write things to the registry
write things to the local settings and
this and that and how many of you have
ever tried to uninstall iTunes yeah you
laugh because it's true I will say that
iTunes has been repackaged as a Windows
Store or a desk as a desktop bridge
application and it is actually safe to
use again auto-updating can be a
challenge because every different
mechanism needs a way of getting it
there if you're packaging just with an
msi well you're probably relying on the
ID Department system Center or worse
mechanism of getting it to your users if
you're using click once well you know
god bless you it's hopefully still
working for you but can be very limited
in what it can do
squirrel has other ways and again that's
where it was designed to help solve the
auto updating while it's still used
problem in fact the MS bill blog viewer
uses that today but there's a number of
different options and all of them can
leave your machine in a state of who
knows by the time it goes away so all of
these have been consolidated into a
single packaging format going forward
for Microsoft and that's called MSI X
anyone here heard of this anyone anyone
using this yet today okay good because
using MSI X is actually pretty
straightforward and is perfect for
dotnet framework or doc or three
applications because what it is it's an
application bundle that you can give to
your users and we'll put mashite bits on
their machine that can be used and
uninstalled in a clean and safe and
controlled way it takes all of the
existing techniques and moves forward it
uses less disk disk space because while
it is installed per user it is stored in
a central machine location so if you
have a workstation or a dense
environment like a server or virtualized
servers environment you don't have to
worry about that 300 Meg application
being on the machine 20 times OS manages
the updates it can do differential block
level updates so if you're dealing with
a branch office situation you don't have
to download a gigabyte it'll download
the different you know 100 megabytes or
whatever the if something changed and if
you're using an application particularly
the with maybe some ml models in it
those ml models can be big again lots of
different things are using a game with
textures or graphics or sound many of
those assets don't change from time to
time and this can be very efficient at
getting those bits to the disk
it also has automatic update capability
that's managed by the system and
configurable by the you the developer as
well as integrity protection so the
whole package is signed
by you and the operating system handles
making sure hasn't been mucked around
with by you know bad things but yes so
the question was does that include
unattended and I'll say it is unattended
for updates there are ways you can
script the installation as well by the
you know with PowerShell so that you can
do that part as part of a user login but
it does need to be done in a user login
session because of the context for
distribution options the thing I want to
drive home is that this has nothing to
do with the Windows Store Windows Store
is there it's great if you want to use
it and there is a store for business but
most places and most organizations are
saying well why do I want to use that
you know it's I have my own internal
mechanism and I don't want to wait one
two three days for Microsoft who maybe
approve my package and get it out to my
users so these techniques with the MS IX
and the app installer configuration file
can be can be sitting anywhere on an
internal file share on an internal or
external web server it's really up to
you so that's really the important bit
is that this is the replacement for
click once it is click it's the better
click once so anywhere you're using and
distributing files or applications I
would strongly suggest moving over and
looking at app installer it is included
in Visual Studio 2017 as part of the uwp
package it is based on similar
technologies but it is not a you WPF it
is exactly what you have today and you
can use it for WPF WinForms MFC whatever
and we'll take a look here at packaging
up an existing project and then look at
a technique that on how to light up for
Windows 10 so that might be a scenario
where we have an app we still have to
support Windows 7 but you know what if
you're running
Windows 10 maybe we can use some of the
windows 10 api's in a cleaner way here
let's switch back over to the msbuild
log viewer and so we've just created the
msbuild log viewer and what we want to
do here now is add a packaging project
so they come back and hit add new
project and if I search and this is the
new project dialog for 2019 I'm still
getting used to it but I can search for
a package package
there we go next and I will give it a
name like the project name dot package
just for convenience so I remember what
it is you word although you can call it
of course whatever you want and it will
ask me what are the versions of Windows
that I want to target in this case it's
a bit less relevant because this isn't
really you WPF but if you are calling
Windows 10 api's then it could be
relevant it's just there so it creates
the packaging project all I do at this
point is add the reference to the main
executable msbuild structured us the
library sorry
and if I build this up now it will
create a package and that's it this will
create a store package that can be
handed over to either uploaded to the
Microsoft Store or something you can use
in a file share and as soon as it builds
here we'll take a look at how to create
that final package again I hate the fact
that it says store but it is creating
any packages create app packages and the
key here is this bit that says side
loading that means from your file share
from your web server it means everything
other than the window store it means
give it on a thumb drive to your tester
or to your user or if your company
already has an internal distribution
mechanism you can copy there that's what
side loading means and there's that also
that option for automatic updates so we
select that we'll select it it needs to
be an x86 app because we are saying that
it has to have a version of the runtime
we want to do this as self-contained
next how many days do we want to have
updates you know is there every day or
every time it launches and there's other
ways to control this programmatically
from within your app give it the some
UNC share whatever
you'd have to do that probably custom
with a file watcher the question is can
you do it automatically when the file
changes I think you'd have to check that
with a file tames or just do it like
every minute you could control the
frequency with more granularity with the
XM or the manifest XML that's underneath
all of this and what it's going to do
here is it's going to build it it's
going to do it in a self-contained way
and in a minute or less we'll have here
the packages here we go and it's going
to show us the folder and it gives us
this app installer file that is the
moral equivalent of the click once file
that's the kind of the Unversity can put
this whether the link to somewhere this
file name will never change and then it
has a version 2 subdirectory with the
file underneath it and it's about 40
megabytes because if we open it up and
look at it it's really just a zip file
and we can see inside that it has a full
copy of the dotnet core framework in
here so that's why it's self-contained
you know you could give this to somebody
which doesn't have net installed this
or.net core installed and it will just
run even better because I hate writing
webpages I mean I am a desktop developer
after all it even gives me the web page
template to stick somewhere if I want to
give people hey click here and what this
will do is it uses a protocol handler to
launch the bootstrapping app and you
only have to do this once this is the
app that just registers that app
installer package with the system and
it's failing here because I've told it
whack-whack fubar and it says hey there
is no such place but you would show here
the package information and one final
click to install it can also be scripted
with PowerShell for an IT department to
say on user login install this package
once and then from there on in the app
installer file controls the frequency of
updates and such so that's a one-time
thing
and if you've used NuGet package
explorer there is a CI feed option in
fact I do this as part of my
see I build you can click within the
github site it will open the app
installer file and from there on in
whenever I publish it
nightly or daily or actually every
single build it could potentially just
silently update in the background for
you so it's that so the question is is a
copying locally in the to the disk and
the answer is yes so the app installer
file and the App X file or MSI X file
lives on the network share or the file
web server or wherever it takes the file
puts it to a shared location on Windows
and then registers that within the user
so if you have multiple users on the
system that are all using the same
version it's still only in one place and
it ref counts it so if there's only one
user and you get the next version it
doesn't keep a hundred versions behind
so coming up to the final demo here the
natural question is okay Windows 10 we
want to use some of these new api's but
how do we potentially build an app that
lights up in is available for Windows 10
but also supports running on Windows 7
and that's where we can come in and use
some runtime detection and I'm gonna
come in here and say if Windows version
helper and this is a custom library it's
on you get called OS version helper this
will save you know lots of nasty pee
invoke code but there's a helper method
called has package identity what that
does is say hey am i running on Windows
10 and can I use the new api's that
means that it's in a desktop bridge
package and registered with the system
correctly otherwise you know you were on
Windows 7 or somewhere where it might be
on Windows 10 but just running outside
of the package and you cannot use those
new api's so that it all that one that
will call and what I'm going to do here
is so you don't have to watch me type
I'm gonna drag this method in here which
says
so use so toast notification using
Windows runtime else worse somewhere
else we need to show toast a different
way so let's come back in here and show
toasts down level so we just put that in
here and the key bit here isn't that
it's using the Windows 10 api's but that
you if you're gonna do a runtime feature
detection particularly for Windows 10
you do want to ensure that you use the
method info options this is one that
you've probably never seen it's buried
in system we know dot compiler services
somewhere what it does though is that it
tells the JIT don't run
don't try and squash this method body
into the thing that's calling it and
that's super important because if you're
on Windows 7 the types that are in here
like toast notification manager aren't
there they're part they're defined as
part of Windows so you need to make sure
that you use the no inlining to prevent
that from happening and if we run this
now I'm going to do is let's publish it
actually publish
so a folder great profile
publish okay perfect release that core
app configuration they just changed this
dialogue on me framework dependent I
want to say self-contained keep
everything together and it's going to be
for windows x86 there we go
hit save and I hit publish and that's
going to give me everything that I need
in the output folder at the same time
let me come in the application rebuild
this
if we run use me I'm so sorry
we run it from the package it click oh
here we go we'll get a toast
notification that's nice Lily it's
respecting the notifications that
Windows 10 has and if I can turn this
off click it again it pops off using the
Windows 10 API now if we take the same
thing let's go to the output directory
we published x86 and the core top three
when x86 here's all our files to care is
take this folder copy it paste it here
on to my windows 7 vm just to prove here
point that this will work as is on a
Windows 7 machine this machine does not
have dotnet core 3 installed anywhere on
it and in a few seconds you here run it
let's go find the EXCI and this was just
WPF app let's go find it run it click
and we have a different toast style
because this machine does not have the
new API same app
same binary works everywhere and that's
that switch back
with that I just want to leave you with
a couple of takeaways one is that now is
the time the Microsoft is officially
recommending that all new apps be
starting and written on Dec or 3 that is
new up until now it's been an it depends
answer now they're changing their tune
and as you know we kind of talked about
before you know use your judgment I
wouldn't touch that app that gets you
know an update once every 18 months it's
not worth it and finally some resources
and some links to help get started with
net core 3 my blog has a bunch of
resources from time to time they are
pretty technical in depth but I try to
explain it and of course if you have any
questions or need help on your migration
project please tweet at me and I will
try to do my best to help you and with
that thank you very much
certainly happy to take questions if you
know we're just about a time but you
know I'll stick around for a few minutes
so